Fearing a German invasion, in 1940 Alan Turing
converted his assets into silver ingots and
buried them in Buckinghamshire.
He spent the rest of his life failing to find
them.
In 2014, a single parking space in London
was sold for £400,000.
The Duke of Wellington's horse, Copenhagen,
died from eating too many sponge cakes, bath
buns and chocolate creams.
In 2013, nine babies born in the UK were named
Cheese.
The International Space Station travels at
five miles a second.
It's impossible to get lost in a labyrinth:
unlike mazes, labyrinths have only one possible
route.
Chewbacca's voice was created by combining
the sounds of a bear, a walrus, a lion and
a badger.
People eat less in subdued lighting conditions.
President George W. Bush was once a cheerleader.
Bananas have more trade regulations than AK-47s.
Taking a photo of something reduces your ability
to remember it.
In parts of Western China, it is customary
to put salt in your tea instead of sugar.
The Great Pyramid of Giza was built by 100,000
people working 10 hours a day for 20 years.
After getting out of the bath, the ancient
Greeks covered themselves with olive oil.
Each day 22% of people skip lunch.
It would take 225 million years to walk a
light year.